everybody it's gary vaynerchuk sitting
here at vaynermedia
working away working on some cinderella
wine stuff um anyway
um there's a little plug uh actually
um i want to talk about something that i
find extremely fascinating which is
12 days ago 10 days ago maybe seven days
ago but probably 12 days ago
google buzz and chat roulette
did not exist and that's probably been
50 of my conversations over the last 72
hours with different clients and people
in the space
i think it's massively fascinating that
people are trying to wrap their head
around social media
and are creating decks and are trying to
lay out 365 day plans
three year plans at least six month
plans and i respect and
understand why but we need to start
respecting and understanding that
internet as a platform
is so different than television and
print and radio
where you don't have to have timing you
know you don't have to have
plans it doesn't take six months of
production before this show comes out
that's going to become pop cultured
and then we're going to have to adjust
to it it doesn't work that way things
happen fast they're happening behind the
scenes we don't know the russian kids
working on
chat roulette we don't know that
google's like we're going to make our
play with buzz
they come out and they change the
landscape immediately because we're
connected
and interacting in this thing called
computer you know
so i i think that one of the big
takeaways
for me and one of the fascinating things
about google buzz and
chat roulette and anything else i mean
look chat roulette comes out everybody's
starting to think about it got a little
porn out you know and things like that
so we're
analyzing it but boom tiny chat comes
out and adjusts to it
you know there's so much speed the speed
of business
has accelerated to a level that i really
really honestly with all my heart
believe that most people have not
wrapped their head around and more
importantly
corporate america big companies and a
lot of
large moving battleships are really
gonna have to think
long and hard about having like those
little lifeboats on the side
you know those little speed boats that
sit in your little yacht there and
you throw out there every company a big
size is gonna have to have that little
ninja team
that jedi team that little speed boat
off the battleship
because you're gonna have to react
you're gonna have to move because this
stuff happens fast
it changes the landscape of the
competitive model and you know
12 months later six four months later
sometimes you blink
and the whole game has changed and a lot
of people are not prepared for the speed
of what social media does google buzz
chat roulette tiny chat's reaction to it
all were not even real 10 days ago